hey guys pete here today i'm going to
explain the protomolecule from the
expanse
remember poor julie mal slumped against
the wall in a room at the blue falcon
hotel on arrows
good old patient zero at least for all
the proto-molecule-related stuff that
happened in the soul system after that
much of that is what this video is about
but we'll also dive a little deeper to
better understand how she ended up in
that situation
specifically what caused this chain of
events i.e the proto-molecule
what exactly that is at least as much as
we're able to understand it
where it came from and who was
responsible for creating it
this mystifying blue substance is at the
heart of the events that shape the story
of the expanse
there is a lot to tell which i will try
to keep simple
and i would say this is the perfect time
because the first phase of how it shapes
things
more or less concludes with the
appearance of the ring gates and station
out there beyond uranus for the spoiler
warning
i'm making this video before season 5
comes out as a reader of all the books
and novellas in the expanse series
but since this is the type of video that
you might wander into at any point
during your journey through the series
i'm going to introduce the information
in the order we learned it in the story
season one stuff first then season two
and so on that way you can tap out of
the video if it starts getting ahead of
what you've seen
i'll also be referring to the books but
won't spoil things beyond where the show
is and there are some differences
between the books and show
but since overall we get to the same
place i won't spend a lot of time
pointing those out
now with all of that out of the way and
yeah i know it was a lot
let's get into it what is the
proto-molecule then
the best description comes from an
in-world explainer slash corporate
presentation to the board of directors
from protogen scientist anthony dresden
in a video feed that's found in the
first book he explains that the
proto-molecule is
not in itself a living thing but a set
of free-floating instructions
designed to adapt to and guide other
replicating systems
to put things in context he made this
feed two years before
arrows and essentially it's his pitch
for that and for continued
experimentation
the protomolecule itself was discovered
on saturn's moon
phoebe eight years before the beginning
of the series mars was exploring this
little ice moon
essentially surveying the resources that
were available there
in that process they discovered some
anomalies they found some things that
didn't exactly make sense
and so they entered into a partnership
with an earth corp called protogen
to outsource some of the work to figure
out what was going on there
they set up a joint long-term research
facility and protogen led by
dresden made several discoveries about
the proto-molecule
they figure out that it's extra solar
that it came from somewhere outside of
our solar system
and that it is actually technology it
was made by something
it is in fact the first technology of
genuinely extraterrestrial origin
so that answers some of our questions of
where it came from and who was
responsible for making it it was created
by an alien civilization
far more advanced than humanity what's
more it has a prefabricated mechanism
for the manipulation of living systems
remember it's described as not a living
thing but as a set of free-floating
instructions designed to adapt to and
guide
other replicating systems i'm repeating
that because that's where dresden who's
the person who's worked most closely
with the proto-molecule since its
discovery
ended up after studying he realizes that
phoebe was a delivery system
and therefore he believes that the
proto-molecule is a weapon
at this point he doesn't know what that
prefabricated mechanism that's inside it
is for
but he knows it was sent to our solar
system over 2 billion years ago and had
it not been caught in saturn's gravity
life as we understand it on earth might
not exist
phoebe would have crashed into our
planet which would hijack any chance of
life as we know it developing
because that started about 800 million
years ago
now this video isn't about dresden but
there is some things you need to know
about him besides the fact that he works
for protogen
and that's owned by mao kwakowski
mercantile which is why we see him
answer to jules pierre he also has some
strange personal beliefs
most importantly he thinks that empathy
is a real setback for humans
essentially that it gets in the way of
doing the kind of research
necessary to prepare for the showdown
that's coming from this alien
civilization who sent the protomolecule
on phoebe
he uses a process on himself and his
researchers
that uses magnets to turn off the part
of their brain that processes empathy
creating ready-made sociopaths in the
show we get this information from
cortazar when he's being held prisoner
after they raid the laboratory on toss
station so dresden is aggressively doing
experiments on phoebe
eventually he kills the martian
scientists there samples of the
protomolecule are taken away they're
transported on the anubis
eventually phoebe and the research
station are destroyed
so those samples on the anubis are all
that's left of the material
in the meantime dresden is pushing for a
bigger experiment with human subjects
in a closed situation like eros the
sociopath believes that what the
proto-molecule needs is
more biological mass to hijack he's
still trying to figure out what'll
happen if it's allowed to
grow he pitches the idea to jules pierre
mao that this is what they need to do
and that they're really on the verge of
the biggest discovery in human history
to pull an experiment like eerosoft they
need for earth and mars to be distracted
so they decide to get them to fight each
other that's where the canterbury comes
in
that's how the survivors of the cant
become the crew of the rosannante
and the one thing that protogen couldn't
have planned for was julie mal
and the opa getting involved with the
anubis
julie survives and she's able to make it
to eros on a shuttle from the anubis but
she's already been infected with the
proto-molecule
she eventually dies in her hotel and
then the crew of the rossonante and
detective miller both arrived there at
the same time to find her
not long afterwards anthony dresden
shows up
and to him this is great news because
now they have active protomolecule again
and in that julie becomes patient zero
protogen is then able to move on with
their experiment they're able to infect
the population of arrows
they're able to speed things up using
radiation and to feed the proto-molecule
a huge
amount of biomass and they set up their
laboratory on toss station to study the
results
by the end of season one we pretty much
understand that the protomolecule
acts as an infectious agent and we start
to see how that affects life
it can infect humans on contact we hear
dresden say that it can't be transmitted
through the air
but if it's wet don't touch it unless
you want something amazing to happen
they presume that it was created to
hijack single-celled organisms but by
testing it on animals and humans
they realize that it can adapt to
multicellular life as well
and in the first half of season 2 we
start to see what happens when it gets
inside a human
how it affects the host and how it
eventually spreads
while things are evolving on eros the
radon toss station happens
where miller kills dresden he basically
realizes that the proto-molecule in the
research that protogen's done
will be so valuable to everyone that
dresden's gonna be able to talk his way
out of anything
he sees that holden who's level-headed
and idealistic as hell
is even starting to get sucked into the
idea of continuing with the eros
experiment so he takes the scientists
out but at least one of his researchers
survived
the crew of the rossi fred johnson and
miller come up with a plan to get rid of
arrows
to use the mormon generation ship the
nauvoo to redirect it
into the sun when they try to do this we
get to see what the proto-molecule is
capable of
when it has the time to alter the
building blocks of a large number of
hosts
we get the impression that it creates
something that functions as a hive mind
it integrates with what's available to
repurpose
in this case the aerostation and can
take control
manipulating things in a way that's
unexplainable to us
the protomolecule was able to maneuver
arrows out of the path of the naboo
and then it started accelerating towards
earth this appeared to be
it following through with that
pre-fabricated mechanism
and it seemed as though it was carrying
out its prime directive to hijack life
on earth
miller ended up trapped on the station
and he thought that maybe since the
outbreak started with julie mal
that her consciousness might still be in
the system somewhere
and i have to explain that what happens
here isn't necessarily
explainable yet at this point in the
story we're gonna learn more about all
of this stuff later but basically what
we see is that he goes back to where
julie died and he is able to make
contact with her imprinted consciousness
he believes that she's trying to go back
home and he manages to convince her that
she can't do that that it would kill
billions of people
instead he gets her to head to venus and
we watch as the station crashes into the
planet's surface
turns out that this wasn't the only
experiment going on
protogen was also infecting humans on io
in an attempt to create super soldiers
while this takes up a lot of story time
in the back half of the second season
in the first half of season three the
big takeaway from this is that yes they
are able to infect humans they are able
to create hybrids
but they can't use them for their
purpose because they can't control them
so at least at this point in the story
this whole idea of hybrids is just a
failed experiment
a few of the things that we learned from
them is that they continue to evolve
they're always in search of more energy
and like everything else
proto-molecule-related they seem to be
in communication
in other words they're a part of the
bigger hive mind so on venus after
arrows crashed on the surface
the proto-molecule went back to its work
it began
changing the planet everyone looked on
wondering what it might be doing
we saw the science vessel the arbor gas
try to get close
it was broken down into all of its
components
down to the nuts and bolts and screws
everyone on board died and all the
components of the ship
and their biomass was absorbed into the
planet the proto-molecule continued to
build for several months
eventually we saw this squid light
structure emerge from the surface
it traveled out to the edge of the solar
system beyond uranus
where it created a ring that's a
thousand kilometers across
and with that we found out what it was
trying to do the proto-molecule that was
on phoebe that was sent to our system
2.3 billion years ago was designed to
create this
ring and i decided that's where i'll end
this first part
in the next video i'm going to talk
about the ring gates the ring
station and the builders and the
additional information we learn about
the proto-molecule when we visit
ellis so at this point in the story we
learned that it comes from outer space
it was created by an alien civilization
that's far more
advanced than us who were trying to
create a network which we'll learn
something about when we go through the
ring
humanity thought that phoebe was a
weapon and while it's true that if it
would have crashed to earth
we may not exist we can see that their
intentions were to build a bridge to our
system
rather than sending a first strike for
me one of the funniest things is that
the name proto molecule
it's actually branding by protogen as a
corporation
studying the first extraterrestrial
technology
ever discovered by humans their first
move was to give it a brand name
and i thought i would close this video
out with a passage from the vital abyss
where cortazar is remembering when he
first arrived on phoebe
he says tucked within the planetesimals
icy layers the joint research group
protogen and the martian naval
scientific service had found tiny
reactive particles the size
roughly of a mid-range virus but with
the design structure
and informational depth unlike anything
earth's biosphere had ever imagined
the proto-molecule we called it branding
it immediately in a territorial move
that irritated the martian scientists
we ignored their protest as irrelevant
our best guess was that it had been sent
from a distance
we couldn't guess at a time when a
defined cell membrane stood at the
heights of terrestrial light
the protomolecule appeared to be a
message in a bottle but one that
included its own grammar books
and instruction tutorials ready to teach
whatever aboriginal cells it found how
to become the things it required we
argued whether something as inert as a
spore might be intelligent at least
implicitly but without coming to a
conclusion the first
evidence of a tree of life apart from
our own enchanted and confounded us
me so the universe reaches out something
we don't understand
sends something we can't comprehend
humanity thinks of it as a weapon
and the different factions inside the
soul system nearly destroy each other as
they try to control its power
in the end the only remaining sample
from phoebe winds up with fred johnson
after naomi wasn't able to destroy it
the opening of the ring gates in season
3 changes everything again
and i'll get into all of that in the
next part of this series which will be
coming soon
so i'm gonna leave it there if you have
any questions make sure you leave them
in the comments i'll try to answer
everything i can
let me know what you think about the
proto molecule and how it shaped the
story so far
if you have ideas about where things
will end be sure to leave those as well
your proto-molecule theories if you've
read ahead in the books like i have
though
please mark anything that's related to
future book spoilers
please like this video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
if you're an expanse fan i've been doing
a lot of expanse content and i'll be
doing that throughout the new season
and the final season when that comes out
and with that thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon